A
DICTATOR.
EVEN A INSURRECTIONIST.
JOINING ME NOW IS TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN TROY NAIL AND
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN BYRON
DONALDS.
BOTH SWORN INTO OFFICE JUST DAYS
BEFORE JANUARY 6TH.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU WERE FAMOUSLY
PHOTOGRAPHED TALKING DOWN A
RIDER AT THE WINDOW OF THE HOUSE
CHAMBER.
THERE YOU ARE IN BLUE.
YOU WERE FACE-TO-FACE WITH THEM
AND YOU ARE ORIGINALLY APPOINTED
TO THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE.
YOU WATCH TONIGHT AND WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, LIZ ALMOST PUT ME TO
SLEEP.
BUT WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
TAKE PLACE.
I WATCHED THE FIRST 30,
40 MINUTES AND I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY TIMES SHE USED TRUMP'S
NAME.
SHE'S NOT TALKING AND THE
COMMITTEE HAS NO INTENT TO TALK
ABOUT WHY THE CAPITOL POLICE WAS
SO ILL-PREPARED TO WITH THAT
DAY.
AND THEY WEAR, THE SAD PART IS
THAT THE INTELLIGENCE WAS THERE.
I'VE BEEN SAYING FOR THE PAST
17, 18 MONTHS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE LEADERSHIP TEAM WITH LEAGUE
CAPITOL POLICE, IT WAS GLARING
THEM IN THE FACE.
WE ALL KNEW THAT THE CAPITOL WAS
THE TARGET.
WE KNEW THAT THERE WERE WHITE
SUPREMACIST, A PROPENSITY FOR
VIOLENCE, THAT WE KNEW THERE
WERE GOING TO BE ARMED.
ALL THE INFORMATION WAS THERE IN
THE INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENT AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CAPITOL POLICE DID NOTHING WITH
IT.
YOU'VE GOT TO KNOW THAT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CAPITOL POLICE
ANSWERS TO NANCY PELOSI.
SPEAKER PELOSI.
IF SHE RUNS THE SECURITY
APPARATUS AROUND OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL.
THEY HAD ALL THE INTELLIGENCE,
THEY DIDN'T ACT UPON IT BECAUSE
MY HUMBLE OPINION THROUGH MY
RESEARCH, THEY WANTED IT TO
HAPPEN.
THEY DIDN'T CARE IF THIS
HAPPENED.
YOU SAW SOME OF THE VIDEO OF THE
OATH KEEPERS ON THE PROBABLY IS,
THE CAPITOL POLICE KNEW WEEKS IN
ADVANCE THAT THERE WERE GOING TO
BE THERE.
>> Laura: WE GET IT.
SPEAK OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE IS MY
POINT.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS OUT THERE,
SOMEWHERE DISMISSED BY THE LEFT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
OFFERED THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
DEPLOY BEFORE JANUARY 6TH TO
PROTECT THE CAPITOL.
THAT WAS DECLINED.
IS THAT TRUE OR FALSE ACCORDING
TO WHAT YOU KNOW?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF
FINGER-POINTING WITH THE
CAPITOL POLICE BOARD WHICH IS
THE ARCHITECT OF THE CAPITOL,
THE HOUSE THE HOUSE
SERGEANT-AT-ARMS IN THE SENATE
SERGEANT AT ARMS.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT HAVE TO
DECLARE THE EMERGENCY TO GET THE
NATIONAL GUARD THEY ARE.
WHEN I KNOW THROUGH MY RESEARCH
IS THAT HOW SERGEANT AT ARMS WHO
IS NO LONGER THERE, HE WAS
WAITING TO GET APPROVAL FROM
LEADERSHIP THE ARTICLE THE
APPROVAL FROM LEADERSHIP IS
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Laura: FUNGUS McDONALD
, THEY AREN'T REALLY CONTENT TO
PUNISH PEOPLE WHO BROKE THE LAW
OR POLITICAL OPPONENTS FOR
THAT MATTER.
WHAT THEY PERCEIVED TO BE A TAX,
BUT ONCE THEY ARE SURE OF GOING
TO HAPPEN GOING FORWARD.
WATCH.
>> OUR WORK MUST DOOM MUCH MORE
THAN LOOK BACKWARDS BECAUSE OF
OUR MOCK RC REMAINS IN DANGER,
THE CONSPIRACY OF THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE IS NOT OVER
>> Laura: IF THEY LOSE IN THE
MIDTERM, IS THAT PART OF THEIR
EROSION OF DEMOCRACY THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
I WATCH THE ENTIRE TWO HOURS OF
THE MESS AND THE REALITY IS THAT
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
PAINT A NEW POLITICAL NARRATIVE
THAT VOTERS NEED TO THINK ABOUT
IN NOVEMBER.
THE DEMOCRAT AGENDA HAS FAILED
AND WE KNOW THE REASONS WHY.
IF NO NEED RECAP.
BUT TO THROW IT OUT THAT THE
DANGER TO DEMOCRACY THAT EXISTS
IS LUDICROUS.
PEOPLE ARE AVOIDING RIGHT NOW
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THERE
IS NO ISSUES.
AMERICANS ARE LETTING THEIR
VOICES BE HEARD AT THE BALLOT
BOX AND IN MANY CITIES AND
STATES.
THERE IS NO ISSUES AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
EXCEPT TO COVER UP FOR THEIR
DISASTROUS AGENDA THAT HER IN
EVERY ASPECT OF AMERICAN LIFE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, WE
HEARD EARLY ON THAT A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ARRESTED WERE
BEING KEPT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
UNDER PRETTY TERRIBLE
CONDITIONS.
MANY CASES NOT ABLE TO TALK TO
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
IT KEPT FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND MONTHS PENDING TRIAL, WHAT
DO WE KNOW ABOUT TONIGHT?
>> I WAS TOLD THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE
WASHINGTON, D.C., GULAGS WOULD
RATHER BE TRANSFERRED TO
GUANTANAMO BAY BECAUSE THEY
TREAT THE TERRORISTS BETTER.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO KNOW.
IT'S INTERESTING AND WE HAD A
FAMILY FROM MY DISTRICT CALLED
ME AND SAID HER HUSBAND WAS
ARRESTED ON TUESDAY, THE FBI
BARRICADED THE ENTIRE STREET.
FBI AGENTS IN THE BACKYARD, THEY
HAD A 1-YEAR-OLD AND A
3-YEAR-OLD AT HOME.
THE FBI IS COMING IN WITH THEIR
GUNS BLAZING.
THE FBI NEEDS TO TONE IT DOWN A
LITTLE BIT, THIS IS GETTING
RIDICULOUS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING AND NOW THIS
INDIVIDUAL IS BEING CHARGED AND
BEING HELD.
HE'S GOING TO BE TAKEN AWAY FROM
HIS FAMILY, HE'S BEEN HOME FOR
18 AND 17 MONTHS.
THEY'RE ARRESTING HIM AND
KEEPING AWAY FROM HIS FAMILY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HELP HIS FAMILY.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN
DONALD'S, I WANT TO LAY ANOTHER
MOMENT FROM THE CHAIRMAN.
>> I'M FROM A PART OF A COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE JUSTIFY THE ACTIONS
OF, KU KLUX KLAN EMMA AND
LYNCHING.
I'M REMINDED OF THAT DARK
HISTORY AS I HEAR FORCES TODAY
AND TRYING TO JUSTIFY THE
ACTIONS OF THE INSURRECTIONIST'S
ON JANUARY 6, 2021.
>> Laura: JANUARY 6TH AND
EQUATING THE KKK, EVEN THE
PROBABLY IS A BELIEF WHERE
MINORITIES THEMSELVES RIGHT?
INCLUDING THE LEADERSHIP.
IS THIS EFFECTIVE?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE'S GOING
WITH THAT?
>> THIS IS MORE GAS LIGHTING
FROM BENNY THOMPSON ON THE LEFT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT WAS
DISASTROUS FOR THE
UNITED STATES, BUT NOBODY'S
TRYING TO EQUATE THAT TO JANUAR.
EVERYBODY REPUBLICAN WHO IS IN
THE CAPITOL BUILDING, WE DIDN'T
AGREE WITH WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH, WE RENOUNCE THE
VIOLENCE OF JANUARY SIXTH AND
IT'S CLEARLY UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT THE GAS LIGHTING FROM THE
DEMOCRATS REMAIN WHEN THEY TRIED
TO FIND SOME WAY TO SALVAGE IT
BACK THAT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
RUN A COUNTRY LIKE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BECAUSE
THEIR AGENDA IS FLAWED TO COME
OUT TERRIBLE, AND IT DOESN'T
HELP AMERICANS TRY TO LIVE THEIR
LIVES TODAY AND GOING FORWARD.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, BEFORE
WE GO I WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
OF THE CARNAGE THAT WAS
UNLEASHED, THE CHAOS THAT WAS
UNLEASHED BY THE LEFT OFTEN TO
NO COMMENT BY DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL BACK IN 2020.
MORE THAN 2,000 LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WERE INJURED DURING THE
BLM RIOTS CAUSING A
RECORD-SETTING $2 BILLION IN
DAMAGES NATIONWIDE.
DID WE EVER HAVE DEMOCRATS LEAD
HEARINGS ON ANY OF THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT AND WHY I?
BECAUSE OF HIS NT FOR AN BLM.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT COMMITTED
ALL THE RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF
2020, DESTROYING OUR BUILDINGS,
KILLING PEOPLE, KILLING LOTS OF
PEOPLE, POLICE OFFICERS, JUST
CAUSING CHAOS AROUND THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
BUT THERE IS BLM AND NT FILE.
NOW THEY'RE GOING AFTER SOME OF
THE INDIVIDUALS OF THE GROUP AND
CAME UP TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THAT FELT THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN AND VOICE THEIR CONCERNS
AND THEIR OPINIONS.
YES, THOSE THAT WENT INTO THE
CAPITAL AND ASSAULTED A
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD GO TO
JAIL.
I'M A LAW MAN, HE SHOULD GO TO
JAIL BECAUSE YOU SHOULD NOT PUT
YOUR HANDS ON ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT YOU WILL NOT
SEE THAT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT WEAR OUT THERE AND HUNDREDS
INSIDE THE BUILDING THAT WERE
WALKING AROUND DOING ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
THESE INDIVIDUALS, THEIR LIVES
ARE BEING RUINED BY AN FBI
THAT'S DOING A HORRIBLE THING TO
THESE PEOPLE BY THE D